i start to feel anxious getting followed
by a guy like my mind is panicking i
actually can't concentrate on driving
because i know this person is just
trying to follow us
a strictly fine list written a book a
west end an internet
sensation you started at 19 20 years old
by 22 you had about 6 million
subscribers yeah that's [ __ ] nice it
was so uncertain about where that was
going to go the rise but also the fall
can happen so quick
the imposter syndrome i already had got
amplified anxiety self-doubt the whole
thing just didn't feel real
diane you met her on strictly first real
proper girlfriend yeah the further you
go in that competition the higher the
pressure is and the stress gets we saw
the best and the worst of each other i
always thought it would be a very
private thing it's actually end up being
the complete opposite
hand on heart
do you think if you'd never started
youtube you'd be happier overall
good question
um
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
joe
tell me what are the most important
things that i need to know about you
from your early years in order to
understand you
uh in order to understand the man that
you are today today i was quite a loud
child i was a loud annoying child
growing up when we look back through
like family videos
um
it's it's quite embarrassing to watch
particularly me because
um i
i'm the i was the sort of boy that'd be
like mommy watch this watch this like
repeating myself over and again and
we're watching it back like oh shut up
like you were an annoying child but then
um at some point
i flipped and i don't know when that was
but at some point i flipped and became a
very
sort of timid quite a shy child
um
always very creative even from an early
early age um i was uh
a good drawer i used to illustrate and
draw a lot of pictures at school
um
which definitely came from passed down
from my parents mum and dad both very
creative in their own in their own sense
i went to a very very small primary
school um in rural wheelchair and i
think there's 52 pupils in our in our
whole school going from there to
secondary school was a big change for me
because that was going from 52 people
was in the whole school to
over a thousand so that was a big which
probably could have a
a reason why
i went from being
sort of
quite a loud annoying child to being a
lot more sort of oh about my debt fear
i'm now a small fish in a big pond
you were i read in the book
in chapter one of grow that you were
quite self-deprecating at that point
in secondary school yeah yeah yeah yeah
primary school i i feel like primary
school i was a
i was a lot more confident
everyone knew everyone very well and i
just felt like a lot more popular then
and then
yeah moving to secondary school it was
much more like yeah like i said it was
it was a very different
place
um and
that's when i first sort of encountered
teasing and bullying and stuff and i
wasn't necessarily like
bullied i wouldn't but it was more like
if there was over like teasing going on
or things that they were trying to sort
of dig
i
very quickly sort of realized if i'm
already sort of poking fun at myself
they will get bored of trying to poke
fun at me so there's less chance of that
happening at that age in secondary
school would you consider yourself to be
a confident child
no
no
do you know what's silently confident
like in my head i've always been the
sort of person where i can
i know what i'm capable of and i know
that
that i think
you know i know that i'm
i can do certain things to a good
standard and i know that i i can be a
good student and all this kind of stuff
but on the outside
not as confident at all so like with
work and stuff i was very confident i
was confident that i'd be able to get
the grades and
do well in school and things like that
but it's more the sort of social
side of it i found that a lot more
difficult
well if i'd asked you at that age what
you wanted to be when you grew up what
would you what did you tell me say like
16-ish 16 i wanted to be i wanted to
work in media but i wanted to be more go
more down the route of um
animation my goal as a kid initially
first of all it was
an archaeologist of course i wanted to
be in diana jones and then uh secondary
school um i wanted to work for admin i
wanted to be an animator like model
builder
um or just i think i've got i've got a
lot of patience
and uh if you know animations like oh
how long it took to make chicken run or
wallace and gromit you know these films
take a long time to make so i wanted to
yeah i felt like i'd be good to do that
i wanted to want it to work for hartman
you your your grades at a level were
really good
yeah which was surprising because then
you know most people with those kind of
grades like gays and stuff would then go
off to university yeah you chose not to
no yeah it's
so we did
uh work experience i don't see the same
like when you turn 16 you have to get
into a dentist did you yeah i fell
asleep every day so
i am
i decided to go roof thatching with my
uncle so my uncle is a roof thatcher
which is a
a very old traditional craft that they
don't really teach anymore it's very
like kind of there's no classes you can
go and take and you can't study for it
you've got to actually go on the job and
work on the job and you learn that when
the master thatcher thinks you're ready
you then go from being an apprentice to
a master thatcher and
my school remember my school advised
that i didn't do it but i went and did
it anyway shouldn't done sorry
but i i so i went and did that and then
um
i absolutely loved it and it was i was
outside i think what it was i was
outside
it was
it was tough i wasn't really i was
lifting a lot of straw and moving things
and sweeping up but i i absolutely loved
it is there's something about like when
we finished a roof we look at what we've
done and it's just
that feeling i wanted to bottle that up
and be like that's what i want for the
rest of my life so i decided that i
wanted to be a roof thatcher for the
rest of my life
i'm the sort of per i'm very kind of i'm
very
bad at making my mind up on things as
well there's a lot going on i'm very bad
at making my mind up on stuff so i was
like what if it doesn't work out later
on down the line i need to have
a levels so if i if this doesn't go to
plan or you know after a while i don't
like it i can at least then try out
university and go back to
trying to
work for
something in the media or or arden or
something
so um but i didn't i'd sort of i i
always like the idea of having safety
nets
underneath me so if something if
something doesn't go to plan it's all
right you've always got that safety net
of
and that's kind of like in a way what
roof thatching became because i started
doing youtube as a hobby off the back of
the thatching did it my spare time and
that started to take off and
and become
a full-time career but then i was
in a way safe going into that because i
was like if it all doesn't pan out
because it's going back to when youtube
wasn't really a career as well so it was
it was so uncertain about where that was
going to go
but i always felt very like
secure in the fact that i knew that if
it didn't pan out i try it for a year it
doesn't work
i can go back to a job that i genuinely
really really love so
yeah the two the two ideas that that
almost in sort of collision there was
this idea that you are
very self-confident in your abilities
and that you've always needed a plan b
yeah i was trying to make them make
sense as two kind of separate ideas
because one of them sounded a bit like
self-doubt this idea that sometimes
there's a struggle to make a definitive
decision and that there's a need for a
plan b
are you someone that has
self-doubt at the same time because i
think it's i think it's possible to
understand your talents but also have
doubt in
the future and
how things will pan out yeah i'm the
sort of person where i think of
the best case scenario so like i i have
those
like i've got a very vivid imagination
so with everything i go into i always
think of the best possible outcome which
then gives me that sort of
self-confidence but then i also have
mr self-doubt on the other side who
finds the worst case scenario
and then they they have a battle in my
head
of
how i should think and it i think that's
where the indecision comes from with a
lot of stuff i live with it i'm glad
i've kind of got it because without like
i would i wouldn't want to always have
the self-doubt there
and i also wouldn't ever always want to
have the self-confidence there because i
think that would make me
a completely different person maybe a
person that i don't like either
so
i don't know it's there's um
yeah i have i have both
that's the thing with them with the
self-doubt if it's just a little bit too
high and i learned this actually from a
guest on his podcast called near iel he
um
he wrote a book on why we get distracted
and ultimately like why we procrastinate
on things and he says procrastination is
the result of us trying to avoid
a task or thing that's that we have
psychological discomfort associated with
yeah so when you're like you know you've
got the essay to do you'll end up doing
the washing up because that's the task
you're competent in and whereas with the
essay you know there's loads of research
to do you're not necessarily you don't
feel comfortable starting yet there's
something missing so there's mental
psychological discomfort so you just go
do the dishes yeah and i think
self-doubt is one of the things that
leads us to have that psychological
discomfort where we just kind of delay
it and wait for that perfect time or
go do the dishes i have that all the
time it's i i always say it's because
i'm creative because i'm creative it's
like i get scared
i don't scared the right word but i yeah
i put it off like if i know i've got
something i want to do that's that is
creative and
requires a lot of sort of sitting around
thinking beforehand and then putting pen
to paper or
or um anything that's going to involve
the creative process
i delay it and i
i think it's a thing of like what if i
start doing it and instantly i don't
like it and i'm like oh this is not how
i imagined because you you sort of
in your mind you have this version of it
it's always going to come flowing out of
the pen or you're going to start filming
something and it's always going to go
perfect to planning and it doesn't and
it very very often does it all just
completely flow
um and i think that that kind of puts a
block in i'm always like
if i'm going to do it i need to make
sure everything's prepared beforehand
that is very interesting a lot of the
time is what we say to ourselves that
we're the reason i'm not
starting it or the reason i have that
procrastination is because i'm a
perfectionist i i really want you know
everyone loves that because it's a nice
way of framing yourself
as being as having really really really
high standards and being honestly it's
kind of like saying i'm the reason i've
not started it yet or the reason i
struggle is because i'm amazing yeah
it's almost like saying that when really
a lot of the time it's probably
self-doubt and that psychological
discomfort associated with you don't
feel fully competent or like you could
fully
nail it and you're trying to avoid the
mess which which we all encounter as we
do anything yeah i think it's like it's
kind of like that i
i think it's from that part of my brain
that's like seeing the best possible
outcome so like let's say for example
uh i'm doing a painting
in my head i'll have that thing of like
almost going ahead cause because my
imagination i see it finished and i'm
like this is it's gonna be amazing it's
gonna you know i'm gonna post it online
and people are going to love it and
things like that but then i
start and it doesn't quite go i'm like
oh actually this is in my mind i've gone
through this process of like doing it
over and over again and getting it to
how i want it to go and then i start
doing it it's not going how i imagined
it and that sort of scares me a bit and
that's why i think i
put things off more from that kind of
side
unfinished paintings yeah a lot of them
too many of them what what have you
learned about is there anything that
you've learned or any anything that's
helped you get past that initial
um hesitancy of procrastination or
because you know you know reading
through your story and even speaking to
you today even before we start recording
i was like god this guy's got so many
ideas i was going to say yeah
that is something that i've
struggled with especially nowadays where
like
going into things like business like
starting businesses and stuff
i feel like from what i've seen very
rarely do you see people that are doing
so many different things and it is that
thing of like i'm a plate spinner like i
love spinning plates of different things
and trying to keep up with these
spinning plates and i
take time to sort of sit back and look
at these things and think
when are you going to sit on one thing
and actually just do that thing
and devote you because you see like you
look throughout history of like artists
and people who have devoted their whole
life to
sculpting i mean
and um i sort of tell myself i'm not
going to achieve
anything sort of near that if i don't
dedicate my whole life to one thing but
for me i just find it so difficult
because i'm like i've got a limited time
and i want to dip my toe into everything
and it's weird because i feel like i use
this analogy and i don't know if it's a
great analogy or not but
with
the youtube sort of career that i've had
over the last 10 years that is something
that i did
sort of double down on and really focus
on my energy on at one point but then it
became a point of
branching out and doing different things
just as a form of like stability as well
because we didn't know we still like we
back in those days we didn't know how
it's going to last for so we did sort of
branch out into different things and i
think i just got a bit carried away with
the branching out and just i was like
there's so many things to
sort of see and try out and do
i see like the that youtube thing of
like catching up like going out to sea
and catching a wave and caught that wave
in
um and it was incredible it was a
record-breaking wave it was a major wave
kind of thing and you know uh
and now i feel like i'm sort of
i'm back out on my board again and i'm
paddling around i've caught a few little
waves but they've not been
like another you know ripper of a wave
like like the youtube one was yet but i
i'm sort of like
i know that there's more big waves out
there
but it's just kind of like knowing which
way you start paddling you know like how
surfers sort of start to paddle out
trying to catch them and you watch them
they sort of get it and then doesn't go
and it's like i feel like at the moment
i'm sort of
paddling out
and sort of waiting for that sort of
next
big wave in a sense why do you need a
next big wave
good point i should just stay on the
beach i think that's actually what my
therapist i have the therapist i speak
to and i use that analogy with her and
she said
exact same thing why do you need to
catch the next big wave why not stay on
the beach you don't need to
go out and
constantly catch big waves
i was thinking this because you said
earlier i mean the question i was going
to
ask before you talked about the wave
analogy was kind of similar which is if
you're happy spinning multiple plates
and trying lots of things and sculpting
for the joy of sculpting
it seems like and this is i'm guilty of
this in the biggest way it seems like
there's this other narrative which is
saying no no no no no forget what you
love doing focus because success is the
most important thing yeah when i say
success i mean like
accomplishment yeah because real success
probably is actually being happy yeah
and you're happy like but but it's
almost
almost like we deny ourselves of
happiness because there's not a gold
medal there or there's not a gazillion
followers there yeah but you're enjoying
sculpting yeah for the sake of sculpture
it's it's like it's like a punishment of
yourself like i feel like i um
in a way i yeah it's kind of like a form
of like joe you know you love doing this
and this makes you genuinely happy
so why don't you just do it i mean and
if you love it that much and you stick
at it and do it then
good things may come from it but it's
not gonna happen straight away and it's
like it's almost like i get into i think
of like i like to sort of the things i
know i love doing i put aside and i
focus on the things that
that maybe i don't love as much or not
as passionate about as much
but i'll sort of almost put that before
the little things that make me really
happy it's bizarre i have no idea no
idea i've tried to i've tried to like
think about it a lot and it's it's weird
that it comes from i don't know where
where it comes from because are you
saying because those things you could be
although you might not love them as much
you you might be able to be successful
in the eyes of the world in them or i
think it's because i've got that thing i
mean it's looking for instant success
and stuff which is weird and maybe
that's because of
like
before on youtube and stuff there was a
time where
you know
we were
i say we like might speak for myself but
like me and a lot of the people around
at similar time that on that sort of
wave that we are on
we all
um
everything we sort of would go into
almost became an instant
success in a way it was like yeah i
think because we like back then
i felt like it was it was so much bigger
anything you sort of went into you you
know it did end up sort of getting
attention and doing really well and and
things whereas now maybe not so much and
i think that's kind of crazy
we signed some youtubers back in that
those days so
maybe not because you were you were very
very early but yeah in
2013-14 we signed a bunch of youtubers
and still to this day none of them were
near near the size of of you and that
sort of british cohort of like youtube
megastars but still to this day i d and
they must have been 18 19 20 years old i
still think it ruined their lives yeah
because i watched an 18 year old 19 year
old kid who had started a youtube
channel got to two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand subscribers when
there was no video that was the only
shop in town for the video yeah yeah
before facebook video and instagram and
snap and twitter video so that was where
as brands we were just pumping all the
money into these youtubers yeah i
watched those kids turn down 15 grand to
show up to a [ __ ] movie premiere yeah
or to just show face when that
when that wave comes into shore and hits
the beach and it's over yeah i don't
those i don't those kids are in a
psychological trap almost with their own
personal expectations of the world
and i and i and i really worry about
that because
success has often is can be a curse
because because of the way it messes
with our own personal expectations of
ourself and of the world yeah and in in
some respects that sounds like what
you're saying your expectations back
then everything you guys touched did
turn to gold
yeah now you're saying it's it's a
little bit more difficult yeah bronze
from yeah yeah
do you want does any of that resonate
with you 100 yeah i think that's that's
a big part of why um myself and casper
is also a youtuber we started a
management company because in the future
there's going to be kids i mean we
already seen it then like young kids
that were shooting to fame overnight but
even i think nowadays with other social
medias it happens even quicker like the
the rise but also the fall can happen so
quick and i was like
for for me and casper we want to make a
management company a big role of what we
have in that is
being in a way called mentors when
needed to
to for any questions they have or
anything that any concerns they have
about that kind of thing we can sort of
give
it's i kind of use it as like a i guess
like the you know like um
the hunger games a guy who's like sat on
the train he sort of takes her through
it and be like look this is gonna happen
i guess like a a
mentor a very different version yeah
like yeah kind of like mental kind of
role yeah um
and that
for me is like one of the like the best
things
that i do at the moment is having that
sort of one-on-one with our own clients
and sort of if they've got any sort of
issues being able to actually offer
advice
and see it make a change i'm joe at 19
yeah yeah and you're joe at 30. right
what do you say to me
i'm about to um but as you were i'm
about i'm thinking about uploading that
first video yeah
what advice would you give me i would
say
if you want it to get to that level you
can do it if you put in the sort of the
consistency and you're you're making
stuff that is gonna get seen and stuff
but just be prepared for
there's other sides of it that
aren't aren't all bells and whistles and
that kind of thing there's there's gonna
be obstacles there's gonna be things
that
that you're gonna need advice on and
we're going to be here to
to help and hold your hand through that
if you need it
press negative press
um
you know haters you're going to get
trolls that's the bigger audience size
the
the more
issues it brings in terms of the more
eyes that are on you the more people
that watch your stuff that might not
like what you do and then they've got a
thing out against you and there's
there's a lot what's the mental cost
i would say
that
if you're me
it's still worth it
it's still
don't ever regret doing it
it's still worth it like you
there there of course there's there's
negatives but
the positives that you've gained out of
it or you will gain out of it
um in everything
outweighs a negative and don't get don't
get
bogged down by the negatives because
there's more pos you know there's more
positives going to be more positives and
negatives
the the negatives don't matter as much
as you think they're going to matter at
the time at the time when you experience
these negatives and these things that
you know don't go your way or
that's going to happen but
don't let it don't dwell on it don't let
it consume you because
there's positives beyond that that and
you'll you'll look back and you won't
regret it what is the worst thing that's
going to happen to me
the worst thing is going to happen to
you over the next 10 years so i'm 19
years old
you know how it all plays out yeah
overthinking
overthinking and worrying about what
other people
how they perceive you
what cost is that going to have
a few sleepless nights
a lot of anxiety
self-doubt guessing at 19 years old joe
didn't know what anxiety was no no what
is it
it's a feeling of
claustrophobia
feeling a bit trapped
um
do you remember do you remember days
through that period i mean you talked a
little bit in the book about i think
2015 or so a couple of years in i mean
so you said earlier you started at 19 20
years old by 22 am i correct to say that
you had about six million subscribers
possibly yeah that's [ __ ] it's nice
yeah it happened really quick i was very
fortunate that
my
uh my sister zoe sort of um and alfie
actually um her partner they
really encouraged me to do it
before youtube we used to um
buy blank cassette tapes and make our
own
radio shows or
i guess by podcasts back in the day like
as like kids we're always taking our
parents camcorder and recording shows
and zoey was very much like
the leader in that she was very much
sort of uh the director let's say
um and i was always the sort of
sort of i just did what she told me to
like i was a little brother that would
just go along with it and that kind of
thing and um so when youtube came around
she started to get a bit of success from
it and she was like you should give us a
go because it's the kind of stuff that
we were doing
as kids or have done we're kind of like
it's not
that far off from what we used to do
but you know there's an audience that
can watch you from around the world and
and um
and uh so yes i gave it a go and it and
it i think back then the success of like
the
some of the some of the stuff you'd film
back then wouldn't it be like a drop in
the ocean now in terms of like how
big social media has got and youtube and
stuff our stuff wouldn't be watched
nowadays it was like we were very much
kind of hit it at the right time
and uh
yeah so i started and it just sort of
snowballed and it sniffled really
quickly i remember there was a time
where
um
i was still
thatching on a roof five days of the
week
and then um i had an email come through
asking if i'd go to fly out to los
angeles to interview simon cowell
and yeah i flew out there and it was
first i'm ever experiencing a business
class flight i still had like straw in
my shoes from like being on the roof
and like hadn't showered like kind of
like just grotty thatcher getting on
this plane like a chauffeur-driven car
pulled up to her house and took me off
to the um heathrow airport and i went
through the it's like a little secret
bit
um where they put these barriers down
you have your own like private security
kind of thing and you go through and and
i was like it just blew my mind and and
uh i hadn't even got to los angeles yet
first time ever flying on my own like
solo
and uh that whole experience was just
like
the whole thing just didn't feel real it
did not feel real it just felt like i
was sort of like living like a double
life in a way of like
like yesterday i was on a roof
thatching and now i'm
sat in simon cowell's
fancy house sort of
talking to him about skype those
experiences
especially when they're really quick
when they go from zero to a hundred
people when that when i sit here with
them often talk to me about impostor
syndrome yeah
because
you as you said you're kind of living a
double life you're like what the [ __ ] am
i doing i'm just drawing my shoe in
simon cowling definitely yeah imposter
syndrome
there's definitely a lot of that going
on um and that must result in
overthinking and doubt and yeah all
those things yeah and that's another
thing actually that i would say to
younger joes but you're gonna get this
thing called imposter syndrome
um
you'll learn about it later
but
yeah it'll be there
um
and i've yeah i've had that even even
now to this day like
even
sort of like even now with this podcast
like i've listened to this podcast all
the time
and even on the way here i was a bit
nervous because i was like you get
like these you know these
incredible ceos all and these people
that are so good at talking and i
struggle to get a sentence together most
of the time and i'm like i even me i
feel like
there's people on there that have done
such amazing things and i'm like
even for me it still gives me that
little bit of imposter syndrome of like
there should be other people there's a
lot more people that should be sat in
this chair
rather than me what's the risk of that
because you know i met a lot of people
for me the risk is um
you end up like avoiding
like opportunities in life and stuff
because
i'm sure there must have been people
that we've asked to come on this podcast
before that through imposter syndrome
said no like they because we do get a
lot of people come here and they'll say
similar thing we've had i mean i can
think of a few people who literally came
here and was like i don't know why
you've asked me to be here
and that must impact performance it must
make the whole thing unpleasant i mean
at least the lead up anyway yeah until
i'm such a you know it does yeah i think
like a good example
for me is is
doing strictly or even um actually
probably more so i was uh
waitress in the west end so i i did a
stint on on the west standard waitress
and this was coming off the back of
doing strictly so my confidence actually
it completely changed me in a sense that
it gave me such a big boost of
confidence which i didn't hadn't
had for a long time
um
and so riding on that confidence i
agreed to do a audition for uh ogie and
waitress in the west end
and um
i remember i kept asking sort of my sort
of my team being like have they asked me
because of
like
strictly or you know will they be honest
and like if i'm not good enough will
they just tell i don't want to sort of
put me in it if i'm actually not good
because oh i'm not too standard that
they'd take someone on i mean if it's
not me
and uh they were they were sort of like
i think you're you know just go along
you'll be you'd go this kind of stuff
and um i remember even after doing the
audition and they said they really loved
it and things like that i still in my
mind i was still like but did you though
what like are you sure like are you sure
and especially like the
the the backlash that i kind of got from
that was
was quite like i mean it's it's nothing
that
sort of worried me too much but there
was a lot of like people that was
messaged me being like
you you don't deserve this as people
that have trained their entire lives in
musical theater
and they're not gonna they didn't get
that
they won't ever get that opportunity
because people like you coming in taking
those roles and so i started to have
like a massive and that kind of like
that imposter syndrome i already had got
amplified and i was like maybe i
shouldn't do it and just sort of but
then i wonder i wonder if there's been
any i wonder if there's been any times
where
people have then turned around and said
actually you know what i don't i don't
want this because
of what people on social media have said
did i mean or given their opinion on
um so that was a real sort of
that was a definitely a moment that
stands out to me of being like
i
probably shouldn't be here doing this
in your in your journey with social
media and youtube was there a moment
where you go that was where i really
started to see the symptoms of
getting burnt out by doing this was
there a year or a time we just thought
[ __ ] i don't want to i don't want to
open my emails i don't want to i don't
want to upload yeah there it was
i think around 2016
17 i think it might be
um i remember it clearly it was just a
time where there was just a lot going on
i think youtube was
like
uh
massive we were you know
like i think at the time i mean i run
at the time i've had three youtube
channels that i was trying to all keep
up at the same time and this was
actually before i had any i was doing it
all solo as well so i'd think of the
ideas i'd shoot them all edit them
um obviously distribute it i guess kind
of in a way market it by promoting it
putting it out there and trying to get
people to watch my stuff but i also had
a
uh a book coming out
which i was working on uh we'd also me
and casper did a feature
um with bbc studios like a sort of uh
like a straight dvd kind of like film of
us sort of traveling around in a camp
fan so there's a lot of things going on
and obviously lots of other different
things in the background
and it got to a point where i was like
my life as a roof thatcher before all
this was there was no
feeling like this how i'm feeling now it
was just i had my s
i had such a solid structure like up at
this time go to work until this time go
back unload the straw load up the van
again go and see my nan give her the
paper
go home go to the gym and then that was
it was that was it
there's been a lot of times throughout
my life where i've looked back and
thought that was like i think i think
it's because that's that structure it
does make you feel like it's
i i was living a more
yeah yeah
hand on heart
do you think if you'd never started
youtube you'd be happier overall over
the last 10
years hand or not
i think i i'm more happy the route i've
gone down
as well i think because the thing is i
can't i can never
sort of
as much as you know i
i've had my struggles online and stuff
actually the online has also been such a
big help for me and especially like in
terms of like youtube and the way that
i've worked with them and personally and
like had support from them has been
incredible so i'm very fortunate as a
creator on youtube that you youtube
actually give me a lot of support and
i've had a good team around me that have
given me the support
and the friendships and the family that
i've had around me
although i went through a time where i
did struggle a lot and i i had that burn
out and i had that sort of anxiety and
worry and self-doubt and stuff
i've
had a really good
set of people around me that have helped
me sort of get past that even with the
the roof thatching you know
i i look back on it now because i'm
so so far down a different path but if i
went back to thatching i'm sure there
were times where i'd be up on the roof
when it's like sideways rain wind
freezing cold thinking like what am i
doing up here like so i think it's all
sort of comparative to where you are at
certain points in your life did your
love for youtube shift though because
obviously
you start posting less frequently on
your main channel yep
to the point where
it and it's funny because as someone
that's kind of observed the whole
youtube journey over the years there
seems to have been this point which
you've literally spoken about where
multiple youtubers appear to have kind
of vanished a little bit yeah and then
they end up posting a video saying
like almost giving their reason why
saying they're going to come back yes
there's another one a year later saying
they're going to come back and they
never come back what is going on i think
i mean i have to see i can't speak for
everyone but for myself personally i i
think it's
partly because
your my audience have all grown up or
the audience i had back then they've all
got older they've all they're all in
there sort of i presume a lot of ones
started watching me when they were 14
15. they're all now in their 20s they've
got their own stuff going on and the
stuff that i
knew how to make back then is not what
they want to consume now as content it's
what i sort of gauge from it
i have like i have i have a guess as
well which is i think very much in line
with what you're saying i think that the
algorithm might have changed a little
bit yeah and i think that
i think a few things happen when that
happens so i think as a creator you get
psychologically demotivated yeah when
you're doing the same work and you're
not getting you're getting uh basically
you're getting a vote from your audience
to say which sounds like we don't like
it yeah anymore yeah and then it seemed
like that happened all at the same time
with that initial sort of youtube cohort
and so a lot of them
because they saw declining numbers and
whatever they were making decided to try
other formats and other things and go
into other places i remember back in the
day like youtube seemed to be much
shorter form videos yep and now you have
a lot of long-form stuff a lot of
55-minute hour joe rogan three-hour
videos on there yes there's always like
rumors that go around being like oh this
you heard the latest this is what now
you know this is what the algorithm
wants and stuff and i i agree with that
to a degree but i also think
you've got the people that take it to
the extreme sometimes and like you know
the reason why i'm not doing this
because of this and i i never want to
solely blame it i think that's why i
don't always blame it on an algorithm
this might go back to me being the sort
of
self-doubting kind of imposter syndrome
type vibe again of thinking like it's
not just because of this mechanical
thing that goes on in the background
it's also because
i need to switch things up and change my
you know who i am online or what i'm
doing online
uh i need to move i need to shift what
i'm doing with the times and i think
that's
harder
than i
then i thought when i was sort of like
i'm gonna change my stuff now and it's i
think it's
more difficult than i thought was there
a point where you you saw numbers
decline and you thought where you start
to think wait a minute this this is not
how it used to be yeah yeah when was
that it was
right before i
said yes to doing strictly
i thought you know it'll be fine i'll
get used to it and try with different
content and things and i started to post
different stuff and it just wasn't doing
performing as well as it used to and i'd
always kind of like prepared myself for
it like my dad actually gave me a good
piece of advice and looking back on it
of being like
this what you're doing now is great but
you know in the future it's only gonna
get more people trying to do what you do
and there's many people there's always
there's always people out there that
have
new talents and stuff and it's gonna
it's gonna change over time and there's
gonna be people that come into this that
have got
you know not saying that
yeah there's many people that come into
it that
have got
super talent and stuff that's completely
dominate and things in it so you unless
you've got really got something about
you
you're gonna
struggle to keep up because it's gonna
get bigger and bigger and i kind of like
i look back now i'm like actually
a lot of what he said
makes sense you know there is you know
it's that's the sort of way it's gone
how do you define yourself now
who are you now like as a from a
self-definition point not that that's
something i like to do to myself i don't
like to self-define but if you if you're
someone if someone asks you to write a
bio what'd you say
it's one of the hardest things for me to
answer it genuinely is if if i'm ever
asked to
sort of sum myself up what i do i just i
think it's like my instagram bio is like
i
i am creative or something like that
because i don't i find it so hard to
sort of pigeonhole myself as this is
what i do and this is what i am um
so i'd say like
it's it's difficult i just like to say
i'm just a creative person
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
blue jeans yet but if you can't wait
head over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
you wrote a book
right
about being outside and in nature
it seems like a fairly unobvious
topic for someone like yourself to write
about so it's very compelling
why why did you decide to write about
this about the importance of going
outside during
the lockdown we're all sort of looking
for things to keep us busy and and i
like we mentioned before i love hobbies
i'm always looking for things to do and
i had like a balcony that ran off from
my living area
and i got into
gardening in that small little balcony
of the things i could do at the time and
the things i had lying around i got
really into it and i was like sort of
like caring for
a plant i'm just trying to make a plant
grow or putting time and effort into
something else
um and and sort of not being in the sort
of
the whirlwind was going on online on our
phones and stuff at that time
disconnecting myself from that and sort
of reconnecting myself with something as
simple as as nature
made me feel so good it took away all
kind of anxieties um
i just felt very calm and very like
it took me back to
my childhood in a sense of like how i
grew up i was very lucky to grow up in a
in a
little uh cottage type place um so
getting all that thoughts it's it's part
memoir i talk a lot about like growing
up in the countryside and like and sort
of things actually living in london and
and all that kind of stuff but also
a part practical guide of hopefully
giving some tips for other people in
terms of like how
they can find their own balance that
suits them in terms of the real world
and social media world it's quite a
personal pivot isn't it going from being
a youtuber who's uploading across three
youtube channels and is glued to a
screen to
standing here holding these pots
yeah yeah
yeah it is very different i think but
that's
that's kind of like how i've been i like
to separate out
like those two things and what i've
realized is separating those two things
out is really beneficial for me
um
but it's but it's in no way sort of
saying that social media is bad and this
kind of thing you shouldn't be on social
media because like it's a tool that we
all use and we kind of like
need to use that in terms of like we've
got a personal computer in our hands
it's kind of like an extension of our
arm we use it for so many things so it's
not saying like don't use your phone
your phone is evil it's more kind of
like
finding a balance that's right for you
that
is going to help you feel better about
yourself mentally
on that point of thinking um
mental health has become an increasing
conversation over the last uh 10 years
social media has played it's kind of sat
in the middle of that debate um being
someone that started a big social media
business i talk about this a lot um and
obviously you know people when we talk
about social media and mental health
they'll say well you made all your money
from it so
and and my rebuttal is always the same
which is
you know if i if i've spent 10 years
within it and i knew there was something
wrong and i didn't tell you
yeah i'd make me even more of an [ __ ]
right just because it had made me money
so having having been like very deep in
social media over the last 10 years i
think we're probably more qualified than
most talk about the impacts it has on us
um the mind for better and for worse
when you were going through your hard
times on social media when you were
having those real anxious moments where
um you've written a few things about how
there was about a two-year period with
when when you'd really got going where
you just had this overwhelming sensation
that felt like it was impossible to
escape
wha why are you telling anybody about it
were you talking to people were you
speaking to zoe your family and saying
i'm getting anxiety right now yeah i'm
also my sister cause my sister has
suffered with it a lot throughout her
career um so
i
i found it i was very lucky that i could
speak to her about it and um and
obviously got a therapist as well um
that was recommended to me um through my
sister do you remember that first time
you spoke to her about it
she was she was very good about it to be
fair because she's been through a lot of
that stuff she sort of
um straight away made me feel better
in knowing that
at least
sort of acknowledging what it is and
then bringing some sort of understanding
to it
um but it definitely definitely helped
having someone so close to me like my
sister being able to sort of help with
that
and you spoke to a therapist about this
yes going to see a therapist has a lot
of stigma surrounding it so especially
men are often very reluctant to do that
because i think especially once upon a
time going and seeing a therapist meant
that i was
crazy oh yeah yeah so
your journey to actually getting into
the into therapy can you talk to me
about that process and what
pushed you ultimately to take that step
yeah i think for me it was
i was
i never saw it as a
sort of
i i don't know whether it's because of
my
sister
once again like through everything sort
of in a way sort of paving the way
through that of like being like
she was
um seeing single therapist so i already
felt like with my sister my big sister
can do it then then i can i mean she you
know if she can do it i can i could do
it so i was quite lucky in a sense it
was actually a very easy process for me
what has therapy done for you
practically is there anything that's it
really helped me with that particular
challenge that i had
it's made me
realize that i
am a i've got a thing about people
pleasing i'm a people pleaser
so i
i often
feel like i can't be my unapologetic
self in a situation
without
risking causing offense to someone i'm
like terrified of upsetting someone or
saying the wrong thing i'm learning
through therapy that how to sort of
manage that and to acknowledge it first
and foremost and then to sort of and
we're working on that at the moment of
trying to sort of work on like why
i have this thing of
being worried so much about what other
people think about what i do
it's a tough business to be in if you if
you have that as a kind of
predisposition has your therapist been
able to offer you any advice about
overthinking at all
yes
uh
more so in like the sort of anxiety
side of things there's three there's
there was i think two or three points
that she suggested and it's like
de-de-catastrophizing
the catastrophe
um using time to separate so like if i'm
if i'm feeling anxious
i've got a sort of
the way you think about time helps for
example i was at um
chelsea flower show recently with my mum
and um
i was i was engaged in conversation with
someone else and i was but my mind was
thinking like there's so much going on
around me and i started to feel anxious
i just needed to get out of there and it
started to make me feel sick that i was
like i couldn't leave and i and i had um
i remember had a glass of champagne in
my hand and i was like i don't know what
to do because i can't i was starting to
think of all these different scenarios
of being like i can't just be sick here
because i'm in like someone's garden
i can't just like i can't just run away
and leave big conversations i'm so
worried about going to them sorry
i can't listen to what you're saying
right now because my mind is
panicking i need to go
i was so worried about how they would
think of me so it's like all that going
on but if you
what i've learned is that if you take
that and think this conversation is max
going to last five minutes
that helps and he's like no that after
those five minutes you can walk over
there and you can be on your own and do
this kind of stuff and it's going to
help so it's like kind of like if you're
going into something that you think oh
it's going to be a five hour
thing or exactly two hour exam you break
it down into like chunks so it's like
i've got okay this two-hour exam is
uh
four 30-minute chunks
and that that starts to make me feel
less
anxious about things and then also sort
of thinking ahead of that whole thing so
you've got an exam thinking well after
this i'm gonna go and do this this and
this and this and when you're thinking
about things further in the future it
actually starts to
make
make me feel more calm diane
you met her on strictly yes
strictly gave you a lot didn't it yeah
it did yeah yeah
what was really interesting is that was
your first girlfriend yeah
that's that's first yeah first real
girlfriend first real proper girlfriend
yeah at what age
27 26 yeah i wonder if
had you met her outside of strictly if
you would be together
yeah because it seems like you would
have done a pretty good job of
overthinking your way
it's we have the same conversation we're
like how lucky it was in a way that
we were
even punting together because when your
partner's if you're if we weren't even
partners on the show we're on the same
show we still say we may not have got
together because when you're actually
with your partners you don't see each
other throughout the week
so
we're like this we sort of see it as
like the stars sort of realigned there
and we and but it wasn't um
it was it was an odd sort of uh
situation i guess it's not it's not how
i thought it would happen i used to be
quite like nervous about sort of getting
a girlfriend publicly because
i would always think what
because i had at the time i had this
sort of uh
large female young female demographic
that were
that really into sort of what i did and
things like that and i was kind of like
i've seen through like friends i've got
girlfriends you know and when they
introduce their girlfriends to their
audience it's a bit kind of like a i
always thought it would be a very
private thing and in my head the whole
time i was like you'll be very private
and it's actually end up being the
complete opposite it's like you can now
watch the moment we met which is
kind of unusual
it seems from just speaking to you today
and getting to know you but it does seem
like that was the perfect way for you to
get past because you were forced
together yeah yeah yeah and it's you
know what i mean in the context of the
show you were forced to spend time with
each other you weren't there to fall in
love but they put you together to do
this very quite intimate thing very deep
journey over many many months yep and it
feels like from from just understanding
you a little bit that was probably the
best way for you to get past a lot of
that sort of talking yourself out of it
100 and you know what you you you see
the i feel like
on that in that environment anyway
especially for me it's like we saw i
feel like we saw the best and the worst
in each other over that sort of 16 week
period
there had been times where we were going
to training in like things we weren't
going to plan without going home and we
you know stress
the further you go in that competition
the higher the
pressure is and the stress gets and
things like that so we we saw the best
and the worst of each other within those
16 excuse me everything is 16 weeks
and um and i was and afterwards i was
kind of like
when we even sort of like had time to
really kind of sort of address
things like posts
um and be like i actually kind of want
to spend more time with you because i
felt like i kind of i've seen the best
and the worst and i can you know i'm
happy with that and it is vice versa and
so um so yeah that's how it
you know sort of how it sort of happened
so the show ends yeah you get to the
final you do very well
and then fun you did the tour yes which
everyone a lot of people do and they
love that process as well when did you
decide that
your dance partner was not just a dance
partner and was
a girlfriend it was it was actually it
was before the tour before the tour was
before the tour yeah it was after the
show finished
um and like a few days after we had time
to sort of like we obviously missed each
other because we didn't see each other
so after we realized like i do miss like
miss spending time with you and things
like that so obviously we had a
conversation had a sort of decided and
to see each other more often and things
like that and we actually then went
uh went away
to a place in the new forest wait a
minute that was very quick you had a
conversation on whatsapp or in person no
no like in person okay so you met up a
few times yeah yeah yeah and then
straight to the phone and then uh we
went yeah we went uh we went to
the new forest like a little trip right
um
and i remember we were getting like
followed because there's a lot of like
um
sort of there was a lot of like
attention on us at the time i think
and um and so yeah we were getting we're
getting followed by
a guy like i'm very like sort of
aware of like what's going on around me
and stuff i think it's i think it's just
from the career that i've had in the
last ten years i don't know but i'm like
i was like that guy who's part i could
see from my flat i was like that guy's
parked there he's a
paparazzi paparazzi yeah and um
this is going to sound really like
really wanky but i i i was lent to aston
martin that that morning
so i went down and i was like this is
the best i should do things like this
more often i get
lent cars like this and i was like and
so i went down and um
parked it and he must have seen me parks
and you knew what car to follow and
later on that day i was driving along
and i looked to the review mirror i was
like i think we're being followed
and then um i recognized the like the
license plate was something to do with
the car
and um and it put me on so much edge i
was like driving along thinking like i
actually can't concentrate on driving
because yeah i know this person is just
trying to follow us
um
so
i i um
i yeah i sort of turned off from where i
was trying to go to because i don't want
to actually turn up to where we're going
so i was like trying to like show you
shake him off a little bit so i was like
right diane you know how to work
bluetooth yeah put on the james bond
theme song
and we had that moment of just like
trying to sort of avoid
um this this guy
who was following us and we did manage
to do it obviously very safely did the
pictures come out in the paper no no
nothing luckily because we were moving
on the move
um but but yeah i remember that very
clearly of that kind of like a moment of
being like
this is not what
i'm used to at all don't know if i like
this but but then yeah that's where we
sort of
yeah that's where you're a couple years
into the relationship now yeah you live
together right yes yeah
how's it going yeah it's going good yeah
going really well it's
it's really nice because we are both
very like she's also one of the
professional dancers so she's still very
much involved in the show and and when
the show is not on she's involved in the
tours and things like that so a lot of
our time is separate and we had one year
obviously 2019 was a year we were like
together
and
but we had our own stuff that we're
working on it's a very busy year for me
and also a very busy year for her with
like tours and and back then even like i
think they do like cruise like i did
like cruise ships and stuff as well so
like
loads of different tours and stuff so we
were away a lot of each a lot of the
time but then when we come together
it's so nice because we've got so much
to there's they say like distance makes
the heart grow fonder and all that kind
of stuff and i i genuinely kind of i do
believe in that i think especially in
this sort of situation like
although we are away from each other
a fair bit because of our work
commitments and stuff
it works really really well and like
when we do when we are together
it's nice just to spend quality time
together
um
but yeah no i'm absolutely loving it
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the previous guest asks a
question for the next guest not knowing
who they're asking it for
do you remember
a moment
where you realized
that you loved your job
when was it and why
and was there a moment when you realized
you hated your job
when was it and why oh
good question
um
the moment that i remember that i loved
my job
was
there's there's a lot of little moments
that stick out but i think
this is going back to like the old
youtube gang so like me my sister um
alfie marcus butler jim tanya a lot of
that kind of
the brickery we were called back in the
day um we got invited to
harry potter world
um
and i'm
i've i'll admit i'm not the biggest
harry potter fan but
just being around like having like a day
out with with that group that first sort
of because it's kind of like our first
sort of big group out somewhere and just
being around these people we're all
going through
the same situation which i really
appreciate the fact that others people
within this group that i could chat to
and speak to about
what was going on and it was such a new
and exciting time and we're all kind of
on that journey up
um and i remember that's all that memory
is always stuck in my head and there's
weirdly there's a there's a vlog i've
vlogged we all vlogged it so it's like
it's actually been documented so we can
go back and watch it in the future and
stuff but
um that really sticks out so what about
the second part of that question the so
a moment sorry a moment where i hated my
job yeah
i guess it was the time where
i had that burnout feeling and i was
i had so much going on i just thought
you know what i actually don't really
know if i want to do this anymore and i
i remember telling my manager at the
time
um alex
uh
that i was like i just don't know if i
want to do it there's too much going on
i don't i actually
can't really
handle it i'm you know and i'm thinking
about
my old job and how much sort of simpler
that was and thinking like it's like but
i had all these things going for my head
of like that thing of like don't be
ungrateful but also i am struggling with
it
um and i guess that moment
would feel like the time that i hated it
but it didn't last very long because
my manager at the time alex she sent me
a like a care package she like went out
above and beyond and sent me this care
package of like a a book and
um weirdly it was a harry potter book
which as you know not not the biggest
fan but
at the time it was exactly like i said
it's exactly what i needed um
so but right before she saved the day it
was um
yeah tough sorry about that that time i
think
um joe thank you so much thank you for
your time thank you for writing a really
important book i think thank you these
kind of messages
in the digital overstimulated world
we're living in especially our
generation the generation that are
coming are very very important and
they're very simplifying which i love
because it's very easy to write very
complex things that are um that try and
make things more complicated than they
are in order to make yourself sound
super smart or to try and trick people
to buy something or to think you're a
scientist but i love stuff that is
simplifying it makes it much more
accessible
um and i think that is that is why i
love this particular book so much but i
also really appreciate your honesty
because you're talking about topics and
themes that on one hand very few people
will ever get to experience with the
crazy career that you had in youtube and
that you're having in the media and all
of these things but but also topics that
are not always easy to talk about which
is
the difficult harder times and and that
balance is exactly why we do what we do
here so thank you for your time thank
you very much pleasure thanks for having
me i can't see wait to see what happens
next so
safe
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where heel fits in my life thank you
hill for making a product that i
actually like
[Music]